the second move which is the most
critical move because most of the
scanning even player will play this move
which is Queen cross defy well against
this we will play Knight to f3 again let
me reveal the plan which is pretty much
similar to the other main plan except
this time why it has a good advantage
because this time we will attack the
Queen so let's see of a plan so what
white is aiming for again is Bishop to
e2 followed by the castle on the Kings
side then play d4 and then play a 4
which has a merit of attacking the Queen
and let's say Queen goes to the FI then
again we can put our Bishop either on e3
f4 or g5
depending on the circumstances please
note the most active square for this
Bishop is f4 and afterwards we will play
Knight to c3 or Knight to D do depending
on the circumstances again the most
active square is Knight to c3 and again
the plan is very simple what he wants to
do is to play a 3b for gaining space on
the Queen side so that is one plan and
the second plan is you want to play
Queen to d2 and again those two rooks
can join either on c1 d1 and even and
again you can see this is pretty much
similar which we have played against
Knight to f6
so now let's see some of the grace you
reply by the brac which can disturb this
plum now before we look at them some of
you may ask why not Knight to c3 at this
point now the problem with the Knight to
c3 move is yes it's okay that right now
you are getting time on the Queen
but once the Queen move you have blocked
your C point and somewhere down the line
that can prove very very crucial so
that's why I will not recommend Knight
to c3 the most dangerous line which has
recommended by EC o which runs like this
so after we play a Knight to f3 black
will pin that night with Bishop to g4
and here we have to play Bishop to e2
afterwards black will play Knight to c6
here I recommend that you do not afraid
and play the move d4 and after very
natural-looking queenside castling by
the black which at first sight looks
very threatening to that tone you just
play Bishop to e3 so you're completely
avoiding the castle at this point and
carried out your pistol OPLAN here black
has a two main move which I have
highlighted by the arrows which are ePHI
and Knight to f6 but against this
White's plan of campaign is pretty much
consistent so let's see each by Turan so
the first move is the very aggressive
looking ePHI and here I recommend you
should play the immediate c4 which has a
merit of attacking the Queen so black
doesn't have time to capture the pawn
and the most logical reply looks like
Queen to a5 check afterwards we'll play
Bishop to d2 in one of my game
my opponent responded here with pressure
to be four now instead of Bishop to b4
if black plays Queen to b6 then there is
a nasty trap exist in this line what
white is going to do is to play C Phi
attacking the Queen and the Queen has
only place left which is Queen cross b2
afterwards white will simply play Bishop
to c3 and that Queen is a goner so there
is a Q trap exist in this line you
should always watch out for this that's
why at this point Queen to b6 is not at
all good so in one of my game my
opponent responded with Bishop to b4 and
I played d4
you should always look out for this
advance in Queen to d4 Knight so that's
my recommendation that whenever you get
a time you should always play defy at
the right moment in this game my
opponent responded with capturing my
knight and after I recaptured he played
Knight to d4 attacking the bishop
nevertheless I played Knight to c3
carried out my normal piece development
and now he played f5 which looks very
threatening because now he's trying to
push that EEP on but I responded very
energetically so first of all I hit that
bishop with the moon eith fee and after
Bishop captures Bishop captures you can
see that Bishop is attacking to piece so
my opponent has to forcefully play Queen
to b6 afterwards I simply castle on the
King side and now my opponent cannot
push the forward with the move e5
otherwise the knight will hang so
instead of this my opponent decided to
create out his final piece development
with Knight to f6 and
I start my counter-attack with the move
b4 so now that is very simple I want to
play the c5 and probably my opponent
thought that he can easily handle this
and he just carried out his
aggressiveness with the move
GFI so now the planning is very simple
he wants to play the move g4 but he did
not calculate accurately and here I
played sefa attacking look me and after
Queen goes to the a6 so that was his
calculations but afterwards the very
simple with a bishop cross night and
after pawn recaptured now I can play
this Bishop to e2 and now we can see
this Queen doesn't have any squares so
my opponent has to forcefully weaken his
King so he played b5 probably thought
that I will take with and % and that way
his position will be good but instead of
this I played a very strong move which
is a 4 and now that pawn will be a goner
so in the game my opponent desperately
played Queen to b7 and after a cross B
file my opponent grabbed the D pawn with
my cross T file which allows me to play
this wonderful move which is c6 and my
opponent responded with Queen to b6
which do you mean more time to that
Queen with rook to a6 and now please
note if the Queen goes to the b8 then
the very symbol will be Queen to 8 and
the a pawn will be dropped as well as
the game so in the game my opponent
decided to counter this with Knight to
c3 but afterwards the game becomes very
very easy for me so I first of all
capture the screen and after Knight
capture screen
I played rook to b7 my opponent plays
Knight to c3
but after rue cross a 7 game is about to
over
my opponent just last for a few moves so
first of all my opponent capture this
piece and after king - h1 my opponent
place came to be eight but after rope to
a one there is no way he can defend this
mid threat and my upon resign over here
so that is about ePHI
the second move and somehow the most
critical one at this point is Knight to
f6 I will show you one of the very high
level game which will show us how to go
ahead from this position
so the game which I'm going to show you
is played by Norris a which rate eight
to seven to three passes Ian Rogers rate
eight to six one eight and this game was
played in Bundesliga 1998 here Morris
which responded with the move
c4 immediately attacking the Queen and
please note if the Queen goes to the AFR
then the very simple will be Knight to
c3 and afterwards a 3 and B 4 will come
in a flash that's why in the game
Rodgers decided to play a active
location for the Queen witches Queen to
h5 and now there are some tactics
looming on the d4 point so that's why
heroes of it responded with Knight 2d to
supporting his brother and also blocking
the D file so here young responded with
the movie 5 and Morris which expanded
with the MU D file as I told you you
should always look out at the right
point to push that pawn to the D file
and that will give a tremendous space on
the Queen side now in this game Rodgers
decided to gambit upon for a serious
counter-attack so he played night to d4
afterwards white will capture that night
and after a cross defy white simplified
more material with bishop cross d4 and
after night cross d4 now white grabbed
so please note right now white is a
clear pawn up but blacks position is
very very aggressive also black has
dropped the white to castle on the Kings
side here other countries with the
Bishop to b4 and now the route coming
into the picture so warez image has to
play very very accurately and he did he
responded with the move h3 so which has
a merit of attacking the knight and
please note if the rook joke has been
occurred King can safely go to the
square F 1 so in the game
rogers decided to play Bishop cross
night but at this point the morals of
which played the strongest more of the
game which is King captures Bishop and
after Queen to defy check the King has
gone to the very secure place which is
c3 here he has to play very very
energetically otherwise white will be a
clear pond up rather responded with
Knight to e4 and one of the which
answered this move with Queen to e2 and
now at this point has just decided that
if he's going to play secure moves like
rook to e8 then it will not turn out
good for the black so he sacrifice more
material to gain initiative and get an
advantage of the open King so he
sacrificed his night and after Queen
recaptures now black responded with rook
takes
so now the idea is very simple it's okay
that black has sacrificed a material but
because a white King is exposed black
has a short-term advantages and it is
very instructive that how Morris which
has handled this position first of all
the model is responded with rook to d1
and after rook to d8
by black model so it's simple responded
with Bishop to e3 so it has a matter of
attacking the Queen and after Queen to
d4 white responded with King - C - so
now it's protecting everything and now
somehow black has to continue his
initiative otherwise black doesn't have
any winning chances because white is a
clear piece up so in the game
Rogers decided to play B Phi attacking
the Queen but here Mirza which played an
excellent intermediate move which is Rho
cross D Phi which has a counter
attacking the black Queen and after rook
takes now white do this check so Queen
to g4 check and here brothers again
attack the Queen with the move f5 but
afterwards the very simple will be Queen
to f4 so counter attacking the Queen and
if the Queen has been exchanged then
white is a clear piece up so Rajas
decline the Queen exchange with the move
Queen to e6 but afterwards white played
a very secure move which is king -
Jeevan and now if the King can reach to
the even square then not only White King
is safe but white is a clear piece up
and this kind of positions are very easy
to play especially if you are
Grandmaster so knowing all this Rogers
rush out with the move
but Morsy would simply capture that pawn
and after Queen to e4 check whereas it
simply played King to evil and at this
point
Rogers resigned because that is not
enough compensation for the piece White
has escaped from all the difficulties so
this game will give you a very good idea
what are the plans and how to handle
Knight to f6 positions I hope I have
given enough information to make you
comfortable against all the Scandinavian
defense more orders please try it in
your own game and you will see the
amazing potential of the system thank
you for watching my video and feel free
to comment on my video
I'll meet you soon bye